president trump not backing down in the
battle over how to deal with the caravan
the president's saying he'll stop
migrants from entering the united states
we are sending a simple message to the
lawless caravans and to the illegal
trespasses marching toward
our border it's very simple turn
back now go back home we will not
let you in we are not going to let you
in
president trump also accusing migrants
in the caravan of using children as
human shields after border patrol agents
fired tear gas on sunday
why is a parent running up into
an area where they know the tear gas is
forming and it's going to be formed
and they're running up with a child and
in some cases you know they're not the
parents
these are people they call them grabbers
they grab a child because they think
they're going to have a certain
uh they're going to have a certain
status by having a child
and counselor to the president kellyanne
conway blasting media coverage of the
attempted border breach
the media mainstream media only wants
you to see the children the families
they're not telling you that most of the
caravan are are males traveling by
themselves
that of course projectiles and rocks
were thrown
at our brave men and women at the border
and they use non-lethal force in
response because they have a right to
defend themselves and to make sure that
others who are
are there are are not harmed meanwhile a
potential government shutdown now
looming with president trump reportedly
demanding five billion dollars to build
a border wall we'll get to that in a
moment but greg
um how are how are we going to
wrap this up down there um you did i did
have a report um earlier today
on the daily briefing yeah i'm sure you
were watching that's at 2 p.m correct
there were two was chris no he was not
not today there were two busloads of
teenagers
who have decided to go home they turned
around and went back smart move you know
one of the burdens
of being a conservative is we're always
siding with the constrained law and
order
perception which means that we'll we'll
always be accused of lacking compassion
there's no way out of it
if you are a conservative or a right
winger or even a libertarian you will
always be seen as
insensitive and especially in situations
like these you will be accused of being
cruel
because they'll have footage of tear gas
and pepper spray and it makes everybody
look bad
the problem is it's actually the
opposite because
who warned that this was going to happen
us
and and when we talked about this we
were accused of being
exploited exploitative or exploitive i
think
all the work so or that this was just a
right-wing figment that we were talking
about
so when we talked about this happening
and saying it wouldn't end well the
other media laughed at us
and then when it actually happens and it
doesn't end well
they blame us so you can't win and it's
actually wrong
i think it's the it's the conservatives
and the people that are for law and
order and constrained
that were actually had the best interest
for this group of manipulated souls
these are souls are being manipulated
by activists and it's it's it's it's a
persuasive left-wing ploy
to do this kind of thing but it never
ends well for the people that are being
used
jesse the i talked to administration
official at dhs who said
that i asked the question what does
success look like to you in a month
and they said um an orderly process for
asylum claims
taken place in mexico that they think
that that's what they would like to get
to and that's what that's their goal
it's a good goal i don't know if it's
ever going to happen um now that i'm a
dog owner dana i'm much more
compassionate i want to let the caravan
in i feel like these people deserve a
chance and then i listen to greg talk
and i think you know what
you can be compassionate and be for law
and order you can be a compassionate
conservative
did
[Laughter]
the perfect person to articulate that so
listen this has to be fixed and it has
to be fixed soon because not only do the
people on the northern side of the
border dislike it the people in tijuana
hate it
it's a huge crisis and for some reason
all the people that are american
citizens
the border patrol agents that are our
fellow patriots that are protecting our
safety
they're the ones who are being
villainized
by the left yet the people from central
america
throwing rocks at their heads they're
the victims
they're the heroes and it's completely
backwards because this president
believes in america first
and the left believes in blame america
first it's an underdog mentality they're
uncomfortable with being
the world's superpower so whenever an
underdog or a third world country or
anybody not as powerful as america
has any sort of assaults on this country
the immediate thought is hmm what did we
do to provoke this
why are we to blame how can we
you know accept this assault in a in a
polite way
because we're so powerful we can just
take it on the chin all the time and
that's the wrong way to think about it
and that is that mentality has really
infected
the thought process of many people on
the left that are okay
with what's going on at the border and i
just think it's wrong i'm not sure if
anyone juan do you think that the
democrats are worried that they that
they are being perceived as being okay
with what's going on on south of the
border
i think that what they worry about is
how president trump
is trying to structure this as an
invasion as somehow
these are people who pers who constitute
a threat to american security in some
cases or they're criminals or gang
members
as opposed to the reality which is that
they're a desperate bunch of people
who are coming and seeking asylum what
we've done is at the moment we've
funneled them all in
to one place and then we tell them to
wait on the other side and of course
there are long delays in terms of the
processes that we were talking about
and so then people get frustrated as
human beings do especially when
they've been through a long journey
apparently about a quarter to more than
with children
and so the children are out of control
everybody's frustrated and anxious and
then you get creative questions like
this i think who created this was donald
trump
he didn't start the caravan no i didn't
say that people shouldn't ride because
they're waiting all immigrants wait
no no no you don't wait like this oh yes
let me just say that previously you had
people waiting so what we've had with
trump i mean you stop and think about it
you had separation of families at the
obama did that no he didn't just like
this and secondly you have things like
you know
gosh go after close the borders he's now
talking about
this is again it's absurd how did trump
start caring
he didn't start i didn't say he
by forcing he said right now the only
way that he wants people a federal judge
has said he's wrong but he said
the only place that you can apply is
through existing
ports of entry you can't just come
across the border which has been the
practice in the past
for people who were seeking asylum so
then you put people in jeopardy
you create anxiety and then you say
you're bad people this is outrageous you
get morgan in here because um
the sheer number of people that are
coming over i think that is what
has definitely changed and dhs has said
that they were watching this they're
like this is the biggest
caravan there's another one behind this
one and another one yet behind this one
and so
something else needs to happen it can't
just be status quo actually i think the
last time i was on the show dana you
brought up a great point and and
a great point journal yeah i have a
great point journal about but we're not
looking holistically about where the
root of all of this is coming from in
central america when we're looking at
all of these countries that are failed
states
we're not we need to look at a regional
approach to this and also when you look
at the border it's not just about
immigration or migrants coming in
you know 90 of the heroin the majority
of the fentanyl
that's getting into this country gets in
through the southern border so
politically you know we're all we're
seeing is because the media has decided
it's politically correct to be on the
side of the immigrants so we're seeing
images of children and babies which is
terrible i could also take you to every
region of the world i could take you to
syria i could take you to afghanistan
i could take you to the middle east i
could take you to africa and show you
pictures of women and babies that would
break our heart
but the whole world can't come here so
we have to figure out
who do we help why and we have to we
can't discount the national security
aspect of this
of an insecure border with drugs and
many illicit things coming across so
it's a much bigger problem but everyone
is just taking
political pot shots at each other right
now i want to just double down on greg's
point because
juan said something that trump is
responsible for what we're seeing right
here
a month ago donald trump warned the
central american governments
stop this we're going to pull away your
aid please don't let them come
he warned mexico don't let them come and
then he said you know what if you come
here we're not going to give you asylum
and if he said if you try to cross the
border
we're going to detain you until we
process you and not to catch and release
and he has warned about this he said
there's going to be violent clashes
he's tried to bolster the southern
border and now when you have a situation
where
all these warnings have been unheeded by
these people and by the media
they get there they throw rocks they
disperse them with tear gas
which is law enforcement 101. obamacare
obamacare obama did it
no one said a word and then trump is to
blame one
trump's been trying to stop this from
the junk no i just said
when you construct a situation where you
force people
into an untenable situation but he did
he did because of the ports of entry
argument which is why they're all right
now stacked up into
or else they could be you know just
crossing illegally over the border and
then you got the coyote problem and then
dying in the desert and you have more
caravans
and that would also be trump's fault
they chose this border